we're gonna finish off by playing a game
uh okay I don't know if you heard of it
it's called I close the tab it's called
the dozens every doesn't see I've never
heard this I'm so pumped for this you
didn't even hear it okay no lay it on me
okay
so we're supposed to diss each other
with your momma jokes and whoever can't
take it anymore losses and I'll be the
judge and I'll let you versus can go I
have a feeling that this will go
horribly it's it's called bull fing alsa
wolfing hey I'll go ahead okay I'll drop
a beat
we need beats for this yeah just to
bring out that extra culture yeah yeah
Jackie one was so stupid she tripped
over the wireless network your mama's so
fat when she got on the scale and said I
need your weight not your phone number
okay wait I got one wait let's gonna
google at your mama's so fat she left
the house in high heels and when she
came back she had on flippy floppies I
can't take it over here I can't take it
off oh God huh flippy floppies